so today we're going to talk about
pattern formation and guess patent
formation is important to me but it's
important to I would argue every single
scientist because what we fundamentally
do what fundamentally any scientist does
is looks for patterns either in data I
in time in space in mathematical
formulae it's question of pulling out
those those patterns from the date and
one of the reasons we plot graphs for
example is to extract those patterns to
make them much easier to see
one type of partner work with over the
past few years and the partner crops up
time and time again in nature something
called the cellular network or a foam or
a froth the different names for this
type of structure but I guess the one of
the best examples of a foam or a froth
so if you take some soap take some water
put some soap and let's shake it up
you'll get a foam everybody's familiar
with that cappuccino frother or if
you're having a beer at the head and a
head in the beer you get this type of
thought this foam like pattern um what
where do we characterize that when we
look at that and we what we can do is
which is we characterize this will we
sketch it out in terms of of polygons so
we can table count up the number of
bubbles which are 3 4 5 6 7 8 sides and
from looking at that distribution of
those sizes we can get we can get a lot
of information but that's really that's
the sort of the mathematical side of
things and so it's a way of giving us a
lot of information but what I really
want to focus on is just how ubiquitous
just how many times this particular type
of pattern crops up in nature so this is
a cross-section to a cork from a wine
bottle so this is the structure of the
ward basically yeah so this bar is 100
microns across micrometers a micrometer
is one millionth of a meter so here
we're talking about a ten thousandth of
a meter but you can see that you've got
this polygonal structure so everything
isn't it's not like a honeycomb it's not
like a base honeycomb where everything's
a hexagon here we've got this
distribution of different sided cells so
we've got four sided five sided six
sided seven so here's one six sided
here's a hexagon basically here's a
Pentagon we've got anything that's sort
of four sided difficult to say mainly
five six sided maybe some seven sided
like here let me count it up one two
three four five six seven yeah that's
one particular type of structure now
you've seen this structure before but in
a completely different context which is
there
so here again we get another structure
which is polygonal we've got these
various different cells which have a
number of different sides and they link
together so that is actually a
photograph of the side of a giraffe
so that's we've gone
a factor of four time four orders of
magnitude four powers of ten basically
from that structure to that structure we
go to something which is sort of very
close to my heart this is called the
Giant's Causeway in Antrim in Northern
Ireland very close to where I was
brought up this is a structure formed
basically due to the cracks forming in
lava flow quite some time ago and if you
look at that structure if you look down
enough from above and again plot out
that the polygons again you see the same
type of this distribution of polygons
with different sizes so time and time
again on different length scales we've
seen this structure cropping up
similarly mud if you take some modern
you dry that mud you get cracks and up
just to relieve the strain and again you
see the same type of cellular pattern
cropping up again
so salt plains in Argentina again you
see this type of cellular network
structure stretching off in this case
into the distance and that again arises
from one of these type of cracking
patterns but what's interesting what
first sort of got me interested in these
type of cellular network patterns is on
the left hand side what we see notice
the scale bar here so that distance is
150 nanometers or nanometers a billionth
of a meter and you see this type of
cellular structure again and what these
are these these branches are made up of
nanoparticles so what we do is we take a
drop of nanoparticle solution these are
gold nanoparticles we put it onto a
surface and we let the solve and try and
you look at the arrangement of
nanoparticles that are left and what you
see is something like this indeed if you
look at a coffee stain on a small enough
land scale you'll see the same type of
cellular pattern again but what I find
intriguing is if you look just even by
eye qualitatively if you look by compare
these two you see quite striking
similarities in terms of the overall
structure of the system and just to give
you an idea of land scale this is a
colleague from whose Argentine Tinian
from computer science Natalia who took
to folt or Center to me he thought I'd
be interested in but you to give you an
idea of land scale so
Italians what five-foot-eight I guess
this is 150 nanometers so that the
disparity and land scale is huge and
that that's when scientists get really
really fascinated and really excited is
that when you see the same type of
pattern cropping up across a huge range
of different land scales but it gets
even sort of better than this because
right at the highest length scales the
largest land scales the distribution of
galaxies in the universe is best
described in terms of a foam like a
cellular network and in fact it's called
the cosmic foam and if you go right down
to the other length scale in terms of
when you get right down to the very
smallest limits in terms of the Planck
length just 10 to the minus 35 of a
meter unimaginably small number again
some people this is open to
interpretation and there are very many
criticism of this but some people have
suggested that when you get down to that
land scale it's best described the
quantum world in terms of a foam as well
so you get over from the very very
smallest things that are very very
largest things you see these these
things these foam like structures crop
up time and time again the skeptics
would say that well you know your eye is
very very good on human eyes very very
good from the human brain it's very good
at picking patterns out of nothingness
and if you look at the constellations
you know we've we've looked at those
distributions of stars purely random and
we've picked out various different
characters we've picked out animals we
picked out different objects so you're
imposing the order it's important of
course that what we want to do is to
make sure that the or I or brain is not
being fooled and so what we need to do
is to resort to mathematics and to
quantify these things and one way we
quantify those things which I guess is
best described using this is some some
work from a student a long long long
time ago actually and what we have is we
see one of these cellular network
structures which were drawing out which
comes from one of our nanoparticle
samples but it could come from a soap
sample of cod from come from the side of
a giraffe any of those things and so
what you do is you count up you can
either do it laborious ly by hand or as
we now do is you get a computer to do it
you count up the number of cells as the
number of cells were three four five six
seven sides etc and you plot that out as
a distribution you also for example can
look at the areas of these cells and you
can look at the perimeter length and so
you get these quantitative measures of
the similarity between different
cellular structures and I think one of
the most interesting wacky off-the-wall
examples of this type of process which
we call statistical crystallography when
you take a cellular network like this
and look at its structure mathematically
is that as a study it from a group in
NASA back in the mid-90s well what they
did was they took some spiders and they
give those spiders or range of different
worth narcotics including marijuana
caffeine and Benzedrine um you can see
from just looking in this case just
looking at the actual spider webs that
have been formed by the various
different types of drug table spider
that you get very different very great
differences and what they did was they
actually used this statistical
crystallography approach to quantify
those differences yes so interestingly
it looks like marijuana and caffeine in
terms of scrambling the spiders ability
to make webs look to be much the same
which is I guess a slightly concern for
me given the amount of caffeine that I
drink